I'm the same as this grimoire without a cover An
existence that can't be categorized anywhere
Who am I and what should I do?
I used to think that
the path I've walked is me
[music]
I'm the Magic Court Dollar
Now I understand We used the power of magic stones from now
on Trying to go against the logic of this world
This man
This human is  The correct answer is
the existence that fate has prepared to stop us
The last stronghold of reason The
report that it is a magic court
Citizens
ah ah ah
After all
[music]
must be
defeated  Rise
[music]
rar
Huge amount of magical power
You
humans stole everything I made my
friends happy days in an
instant It
's not like I'm going against the reason I'm punishing the humans for the basics